Matt asks how would you promote a
Kickstarter campaign beyond providing
content to raise awareness and reach
funding goals Matt you know whether i'm
bubbling on this no no i'm stick
d-roc i just told you that i'm not
getting on any of my mistakes Jesus with
this guy
all you editors are same we want to take
out the natural off them you guys like
when I struggle with my words because it
happens so rarely I treat Kickstarter no
different than anything else just cuz
you have an ice thing that you want to
do and you decided to do it on
Kickstarter because that's a platform
that has virality back to the question
about medium and Linkedin that's fine
the answer is the same Facebook dark
posts targeting people that give a crap
about ice cream and Isis putting out
content and blog forum guest
contributing I would literally email
every single person that has a blog of
any size or magnitude that plays in your
space I didn't look deeply but if you're
in organic Isis or just Isis or desserts
or ice cream culture I would map out the
700 people that are in that space that
have blogs or media outlets and reach
out to them and say I'd like to guest
contribute talk about Italian ices
or ice cream or desert culture in
America or the world generally not
spamming like I want to tell you about
my product it's all about being content
and not being about infomercials too
many of the people watching this show
and the rest of the world when they
think about content they hear Billy Mays
and infomercial when I think about
content
I hear New York Times and scandal get it
it's about making that decision and so
getting distribution putting out good
content and that means guest
contributing Facebook dark posts if
you've got money to drive towards it
reaching out to influencers and chefs
that are in the dessert space to see if
you can JV what I would call Business
Development hey you know Mario Batali
here's what I can do for you give you
eight percent of my company if you can
get me the spark that starts out my
awareness hey Carla hall I think you're
amazing and you're Southern cuisine I'll
give you five years worth of my product
for free if you give me a little love
how can you give me love a tweets not
enough so it's bizdev it's content
creation that's not infomerge
but actual content and then it's proper
internet marketing which right now to me
is creme de la creme is Facebook dark
posts